what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be talking about
how we can model and document a very
small project but taking it in a lot
more detail
today we're going to be looking at a
design i recently did but really
breaking it down into its key elements
looking at how it transitions from the
ground to the slab
all the way up through to the walls and
all the way
to the roof structure itself we're going
to be trying to keep it
relatively simple throughout worldwide
standards
so most of this information will be
somewhat applicable to most people
obviously architecture is very site
specific so
this may or may not be applicable to you
100 but it should give you an extremely
good idea of how you can design and
document in archicad 24. so today we're
going to be starting with the arcad
24 template in the australian standard
mode
i've changed absolutely nothing to help
you guys follow along with the tutorial
as best as possible so what i'm going to
teach you is exactly how
the floor connects to the ground the
wall connects to the floor
and so forth moving up it is best that
we start with some sort of a generic
floor so we're going to use it like the
mesh tool site mesh
is a perfect layer that we can work off
and we're just going to use a
rectangular geometry to start with
so for the time being let's make it 25
meters by 25 meters
it does not really matter what this
floor
is actually going to be because we don't
really need it for anything in
particular it's
just there for visual appearance if we
go into our 3d model
you're going to see straight away that
we've created that
site mesh now going back to our ground
floor plan
you can either use this project map or
the view map
personally i like the view map and all
the settings here over anything else
because you can actually coordinate it
and you can allocate it how you like it
to be so for anybody starting out in
archicad 24
you'll see that there's sketch design
design development exchange notes
drafting aids batch render schedules and
audit
most of these things would be null and
void for me on a personal template it
would be more so constructed on the
pages
that i require so things like proposed
site plan ground floor plan elevation
sections and so forth you have a lot of
that in these folders themselves
but we're not really going to dive into
any of that at the moment
we're going to be using timber frame
construction in this situation because
it's more applicable to the rest of the
world
however we don't really know what we're
designing yet so we're going to start
with a floor plan
and then we're going to work our way up
as quickly as we can it's not going to
be anything special
so i'm actually just going to use a fill
tool to start diagramming
what i think might work for a floor
plate so if we go
anywhere from 3 meters by three meters
for a kitchen and dining and then we
also
duplicate that for the living room we're
going to use this three meters by three
meters
for a bathroom and a hallway and also a
bedroom
which then means we can also implement
some sort of decking our fresco area
here
that's going to be the general floor
plan for us for the time being
so that means we can actually utilize
this shape
move it somewhere to the middle of our
floor plan and we can establish that
this is going to be
our timber slab moving forward so
there's a very easy way you can create a
timber slab that gives you no details
whatsoever
you can go to the timber slab and just
trace this but in this instance i want
to show you guys the exterior and the
perimeter of how this will
actually work so in this case we're
going to start by using the beam tool
and we're going to open up the beam
settings we're going to start using a
120
by 45 millimeter timber beam
and we're just going to change the
settings of it from
general structural to timber i'll also
change the materials of it while we're
here
just so we know that it is timber but
basically what would happen in this
instance is there would be a ring beam
around
this entire perimeter floor so we draw
our ring beam
going all the way around and then we
would take this one beam
go to the multiply tab spread it 450
millimeter centers
in australia that's quite a common
spacing and we can definitely use that
for this project
so we'll delete that last ring beam and
we'll select
the remaining that are a little bit over
reducing them back in line
with the edge you can also use the axe
tool to quickly
just cut and trim then delete all those
ring beams extra so you don't have to do
them individually
and we can probably also go through and
delete
all of our fills that we created before
to understand
what the shape of this building is going
to be so if we go back into 3d
we'll see that our floor plate has
started to create
and the slab is definitely way too high
so i'm going to drop that about 500
millimeters just so we can really see
what we're working with
but that is the basis of the floor that
we're going to be working with
and then in the opposite direction so if
we go back into our ground floor plan
we're going to be running timber joists
in the opposite direction
now these timber joists will depend on
the site soil conditions
and what the engineer has to say but in
this instance we're just going to
continue to use the exact same timber
beam
to be a bearer underneath so this bearer
would
actually replicate in this section here
so we'd
duplicate that one and run it underneath
then i'd also
duplicate it to the center and duplicate
it to the end
so dragging it back in line going back
into our 3d
we'll see that we've created these three
barriers that sit underneath and i'm
going to drop them
directly underneath so now we have our
supporting bearers
sitting underneath the timber floor
structure and
positioning it correctly in line with
the above
bracing now on top of that timber floor
we'd probably have a 16mm
particle board so if we were just to go
to slabs general
and outline that shape again we could go
back into 3d and edit that for a 16mm
particle board so we see that slab has
been created it's definitely too thick
opening up the settings and changing it
to a basic structure composition
we can change that to 16 millimeters
change that
to a timber floor and change all of that
to just timber for the purposes
of visual effects that'll obviously sit
on top of those timber joists what would
usually happen in this instance is we
could go ahead
and either carpet it or tile it or do
whatever we needed but from a
construction point of view
that is the simple premise of what is
required
if there was for example a bathroom here
like we're planning it
we would actually notch out all of these
timber joists
and set it down by about 30 or 40 ml to
allow
the fall of the tiles i won't go into
detailing every single one of those
pieces because that would take way too
long
but that is something that you can
expect from your structural engineer to
advise you
of what these timber joists underneath
are going to look like
if a set down is required now because
we've established our floor plate we can
go further back
and design backwards i know it's a
little bit odd but obviously you're not
going to build without a floor plan
so you have to start designing your
floor plan before you understand your
structures
so if we go back into our ground floor
plan and click
control 7 we can create a new floor
below and call it footings
we're going to reduce it anywhere from
300 to 500 mil it doesn't really matter
for the time being
because this is more of a
demonstrational video than an exact
engineering video
i'm not an engineer i'm an architect so
it's a very different
set of skills that we have engineers
will definitely be able to advise you
on the structural requirements and it's
very job specific
so if we click ok and come across to our
footings on the right hand side
we will see that our ground floor is
still showing
and we can go ahead and come across to
the slab tool
opening up the settings going back to
basic creating maybe a 500
deep slab dropping at five
600 mil underneath the ground and
going concrete what i want to do now is
draw a simple 500 by 500
stump footing underneath this corner
and replicate that in all the corners in
this project to keep the distribution of
all loads pretty even i'd expect a
structural engineer to give me a basic
pattern like this
so there'd be concrete thumb footings
underneath the ground
at roughly this sort of pattern what
would then happen is there'd be a
stirrup
set into that concrete and then there'd
be a timber column
or a timber post holding up this floor
structure above the ground
so if we go into objects and tools open
up our settings
type in stirrup up the top archicad has
one on the bim components website so
we'd actually have to download and embed
it in this case
so there's a bunch of settings that we
can play with and adjust depending on
what we need
it would be completely different in
every situation but we're just going to
use the standard stirrup for the purpose
of argument
we're probably going to need a bit more
than 350 let's go 450 in this instance
because you want that floor to sit at
least 300 ml above the natural ground
so we don't get any moisture issues or
anything of those sorts
we'll go ahead and stick a random
stirrup in all of these concrete
footings and then we'll move back into
our 3d
to understand how this is all working so
there are all of our stirrups in the
center of our concrete footings and
lining up
with the perimeter beam of our floor
structure in 3d we'll see that we're
completely off with all of our settings
but that's not an issue we can click
ctrl
f to open up our find and select tool
we'll click the copy settings add
a name parameter and then we can quickly
go
plus to highlight all of these stirrups
and move them 450 below ground so what
you'll see now
is that our concrete mass footings are
sitting quite low
underneath the ground surface because
we've already reduced that
natural ground by 500 mil so what i'll
do
is simply increase that to minus 100
and just showcase that exactly how these
stirrups would be sitting
so if this was actually in its own
element i'll move this across so i can
display it a bit better
that concrete would be sitting
approximately a hundred mil underneath
the ground
and this stirrup would be set quite deep
into the concrete slab
sitting into the center and being able
to hold a post that would then support
this floor
so in this instance i'll undo all of
those to be able to actually
raise all of my settings okay so i'm
going to move my concrete stumps back
200 millimeters or 100 millimeters under
the ground
and i'm going to find all of my stirrups
select them at the same time
and reduce them a lot lower into the
ground
so they're going to be sitting just off
the ground in this instance
we're going to go back into our footings
and we're going to start creating a
couple columns
where those stirrups are actually going
to be utilized
so the column in this instance i think
the stirrups are actually 75 by 75
and we're going to make them timber
again i'm not really worried too much on
what these are i'm not really looking
into it
it would be more so of a timber stud
than anything else but again that
doesn't really matter
so i'm going to go in here and create my
first one just there in the center of
the stirrup
which is going to load in 3d and i'm
going to double check that the sizing is
correct so
what i'm going to do is drop it so it
sits underneath
that bearer here that bearer would
actually extend all the way to the edge
of that
and that post or that column would pick
up the bottom of this floor
that would then be replicated on the
rest and there would be a bolt
running directly through that timber
stirrup
as there would be some sort of
mechanical connection
for that timber to that bearer so if
we'll quickly replicate all the rest of
those timber posts we would see that
they're all sitting on those stirrups
they're lifting this floor above our
natural ground
and we have a good 300 millimeters
clearance from the natural ground level
roughly give or take but for the
purposes of this design we're not going
to worry about it too much
that is a very basic very simple timber
floor structure that we would be using
to actually be able to understand how a
timber framed
building comes together what we can then
go ahead and do is start actually
creating some interior walls
so if we go back to our ground floor
plan we can see our main
slab and we'd start using some timber
walls so again just like the slab tool
there's the easier way to do it and it's
the hard way to do it
timber walls aren't usually constructed
to that much detail in archicad
but i will break it up to show you how a
timber wall is constructed as well
if we were to just pick the generic
timber wall let's go a 90 mil stud
partition
keep it as timber framing and just line
the perimeter of this building
we would have our timber walls
constructed relatively quickly
now those timber walls are linked to the
first home story i don't want to link
them
in this case we only want a 2 4 ceiling
we want to make them quite low
it will sit approximately 10 mil past
the edge of the actual timber flooring
because what would happen in real life
is that cladding on the outside would
run all the way past
these timber floor bearers and joists so
that we could hide the ugly
structural parts of this building now
that timber wall obviously isn't
constructed with a big block of mass
so if we were to actually open up this
timber wall and showcase what the inside
would look like
let's say we cut this timber wall in
half
move it across what we would actually
have is
a 90 by 90 column on each
side of that opening so that would be
our interior of our timber we would have
that 90 by 90 again at
600 centers in this case potentially a
little bit more depending on the timber
size
depending on where we're using it so it
would look
something along those lines we would
have our four columns here
and then there'd be a bottom chord and a
top chord and there'd be some nogging as
well
so basically what i mean there is there
would be some sort of general beam
that would be near identical it would
probably be 190 by 45
but in the thin opposite direction and
all it would look like
is a bottom beam there
i'll go back into 3d to showcase what
we're talking about here
so each of these columns would be the
same height as the actual overall wall
again linked to the first floor we know
the first floor is three meters so we're
just going to go minus 600 back to
four that bottom cord that we created is
actually sitting inside of our floor so
we're going to go back into our floor
plan
and find that bottom cord just elevated
150 millimeters for the time being so we
can find it
there it is we'll drop that to the
bottom in line with
that 15 that 16 16mm plywood will also
create a top cord
just here and the rest of this wall
would be something along the lines
of nogging in between so by that i mean
it would be simple
timber bracing one roughly there and the
overall wall looking something like this
obviously depending on the wind loads
depending on a whole bunch of different
things
it will actually implement how many
noggings we need what kind of fixing
mechanisms you need
what the span can be etc etc but the
general premises of a timber wall
is something along this line we have the
columns at 600 spacing we have the top
cord we have the bottom cord and we have
our noggins in between
on each side if we zoom into this wall
we can see we have
our sheet of plasterboard on the
interior and we have a sheet of cladding
on the exterior as well so that is what
you would see
if you were to break open any timber
wall if you're wondering how this timber
frame actually connects to the floor
it would be mechanically fixed so there
would be actual
bolts directly fixing this at a certain
number of spacing again depending on the
wind
loads of that site and the requirements
in your country
how frequently we'd have to fix this
actual section of the timber wall to the
floor but it would be mechanically fixed
to the actual structure now because we
don't actually need to see any of that
information i can go ahead and just
delete that because that was literally
there
just to showcase to you guys what the
interior of a timber wall looks like so
i'll delete that one
delete this wall select the perimeter of
those two walls and click
control i to automatically join them now
if this was an architectural project
this exterior wall would once again
continue three meters inside to create
that bathroom we'd drop that
two meters to be able to create a one
meter passage come back
line it up with the externals and create
our bathroom
we would then extend that length of the
wall to create our bedroom
so if we were to simply drop a door in
each section there'd be a door here for
the bathroom
there would be a door again here for the
bedroom
and then we could implement our kitchen
over here we could implement our dining
over here
and our living over here if we wanted to
introduce some decking over this
end we could most likely just simply
drag that wall back here from an
architecture point of view
create our kitchen living dining in this
space it would be a very small
kitchenette wherever it would go we'd
probably pop a door from the main side
just here so we can enter into this
building then this would be some sort of
glass sliding door
so if we just select a standard ox xo
sliding door
and implement it here into our project
we can see that we have a new sliding
door we have our front door we have our
interior doors that would definitely be
a different size because these are too
large
so we bring that back down to 800 doors
again we're not really documenting or
discussing anything of the sort
in this project so we're just keeping it
very simple if we go back into our 3d
we're going to see that we've created
our sliding door here we've pushed back
our interior to create this decking here
and we've given ourselves a front door
so overall we're starting to create some
sort of design and some
sort of architectural elements with the
structural design that we're talking
about today
now to give this some architectural
flair and to create something really
nice what i'd actually do in this
instance
is raise this wall up to about three
meters
and then pivot a roof off that section
all the way through to this section
allowing us for some highlight windows
and then
reverting this roof back in here so the
simplest way to do that is to go to our
first floor plan which is
technically our roof plan right click
our ground floor goes
show us trace so we understand exactly
where our building is
come into our roof tool select the
single geometry
and start drawing our roof
from all the way there to cover our
decking running all the way back we know
we're going to have a wall
continuing along this so we're going to
stop that short here
run that back run it all the way across
we're going to do the same
on this instance but in this case this
roof is actually going to cut
that section and revert in at this point
i'll talk about why we're cutting back
in here
and we're not actually running through
all the way in a second but if we go
back to our 3d
we'll see that we've created incredibly
thick incredibly large
roof structures so if i open up this
generic roof
is 250 deep which probably isn't too far
off what a roof structure would be in
this instance it'd be 190 ml timber roof
rafter
as would this one on this side however
this one
would sit on a top plate on this side
and i don't like that from an
architectural point of view so that
would be potentially
a 10 degree roof and this one still for
my liking is sitting a little bit too
low so i'm going to
raise that up 25 degrees and raise that
another 500 mil
so because this is quite a high timber
wall we're probably going to need some
steel columns in here
to actually support the height of that
wall but
again for the purposes of argument we're
not going into that much detail
we are going to increase the height of
this wall all the way to the top
as we are with this wall here so they
surpass
the edge of that roof structure what
we're going to do is quickly select both
these walls come into design
go solid element operations and then
select these two rubs and click add as
operator
subtracting with an upwards extrusion
clicking ok
and now we have our roof and our walls
aligned exactly where we need them
if we go back into our first floor plan
and hold the alt
key we can actually copy the settings of
our wall below
and replicate a brand new wall above
just here
now this wall won't go all the way
across it'll go
to the edge of this roof here but it
will span
along the wall underneath for
construction purposes we don't need that
wall to go all the way to the top
it'll sit just underneath that rafter
and that rafter will go all the way
across
to the top of that wall and sit on the
actual top of the wall now similar to
the floor structure the roof has a very
similar construction method
it wouldn't be just one large plank of
timber it would be individual rafters
and purlins running across the top so to
actually give you a better understanding
of what that would look like i'm going
to create
a little section here in the middle that
would actually showcase what a roof
would look like
so if we take this section here and
simply just
cut that roof for the purposes of
argument drag it across
we open up our roof so we know what
we're looking at
we would see a beam underneath it would
be a 190 by
45 timber rafter and it would be
on the same angle as the roof itself
which is five degrees in this instance
we would run that all the way up to the
top and we would have that
something along the lines of 600 spacing
depending on what the actual
construction zone is what the side is
what the requirements are from wind
loadings and what your structural
engineer really has to say
so at the end of the day is the
structural engineer that will determine
the spacing
of your roof rafters but
in this instance we're just really
creating it to showcase what this roof
would look like
now this roof isn't spanning very far it
is
too high again in this instance so we'll
drop that back down
and it wasn't 5 degrees my mistake it
was 10 degrees we
changed that so your roof rafters would
look
something like this there would be some
sort of l plate bracket on
this side here fixed to the wall and
also fixed to the rafter to hold it in
place
and then what would occur is a simple
purlin would run in the opposite
direction
so if we were to get a timber purlin
again it would potentially be 35
by 35 purlins and they would run
in the complete opposite direction so
we'd run them across this side and we'd
space them at 1200 centers
depending on the size it changes so if
you get bigger purlins you can span
further if you get smaller purlins
you have to span shorter distances so in
this instance we've created our
purlins they definitely don't need to be
at any degree in this
case so we run them flat we will run our
first one
to the top of that rafter and then the
next one will sit directly above
that and the last one will obviously sit
again in
line with the top of the next rafter so
it follows that five degree pitch
but it sits on top of the actual rafters
themselves what these rafters allow us
to do
is actually provide the sheeting and
consistently bolt
the roof sheeting across the top so if
we were to click on our roof structure i
use
cat image tools go coverings go roof
covering
and come across to a corrugated
sheet roof it doesn't need to be purple
it can be black now that ci tools
creates
quickly that roof structure above and we
can see what our roof structure is
actually doing
so on the side here we have our barge
board covering the edge of
that timber roof that barge board would
actually extend a little bit further in
this case because it isn't
deep enough so if we went back into our
barge board change match fascia and made
it 220 for
this instance we'd see that our barge
board now covers
the edge of that roof rafter there
what would actually happen in this
instance is the cladding would come up a
little bit higher
to sit underneath the gutter fascia
just like that so the wall actually
wouldn't extend it would just be the
cladding that extended
so i'll undo that because it caused me a
headache with all the twitching and
jittering but that gutter would sit over
the top of that edge rafter
and we would then actually be able to
see
that our purlins are sitting on top of
this roof sheeting
so the roof sheeting would be directly
fixed mechanically via a set of screws
to these purlins at 1200 centers so
you'd see
screws screws screws every so often
across
this roof sheeting to hold it down if we
were looking at it from an interior
construction point of view
and we had for example a roof lined on
the rake
we would then either direct stick our
ceiling to this
rafter beam here or we would create
another set of purlins that would
suspend
from this rafter to be able to give us a
flat ceiling it really depends on the
architectural style we're going for and
looking for anyway that is the general
premise of construction with timber
frame
it sits on the ground very lightly it
comes up through the ground with metal
stirrups and timber posts and then it
sits on
floor joists and bearers again those are
indicated by the structural engineer of
what size they need to be
the wall itself is consistent of top
cords and bottom cords and columns in
between or timber posts
and then there's nogging in between to
make sure that timber wall is braced
correctly
when we move up to the roof the roof
again is a series of
timber rafters that run all the way
across and then some purlins running in
the opposite direction
to allow us to actually mechanically fix
our roof sheeting to the roof itself
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below drop a
comment let me know
what your favorite part was and as
always
i'll see you next monday